[Musica]
grazie
ciao a tutti mi chiamo vanno ad hera è
questo il mio lavoro e la mia passione è
quello che sono adesso però torniamo un
attimo indietro un po di anni
io quando ero piccolo ero grasso non
portavo mai le mutande per che le
vedevano accessorio inutile
ero abbastanza sporco perché non mi
piaceva lavarmi il mio migliore amico e
un cinghiale e vivevo nel bosco la mia
vita era quesito che mi piaceva era un
po disadattato no però quello è quello
che volevo fare
ma soprattutto io off ho inseguito fin
da piccolo la voglia di stare vicino
alla morte
non so come mai perché alla fine aver
paura stare vicino alla morte mi fa
sentire vivo mi mi provoca piacere
quindi la strada che ho scelto
ovviamente uno degli sport più
pericolosi al mondo e freestyle
motocross questo ma mi fa proprio godere
mi fa godere la vita mi piace mi fa
sentire vivo mi fa sentire diverso mi fa
sentire speciale quindi tutte queste
emozioni al limite che mi fa vivere la
moto che mi fa vivere questo sport
a un certo punto della mia vita ho
iniziato a pensare perchè ne devo solo
godere io di questo posso farlo godere a
tutti perché tutti hanno il diritto di
goderne quanto le sto godendo io adesso
e allora nel 2009 mi è venuta in mente
questa questa bellissima storia che è la
moto terapia che adesso potremo far
vedere il video intanto la moto terapia
è nata dal mio cuore è una cosa assurda
perché è talmente semplice che mi sono
chiesto perché mai nessuno ha mai
pensato perché la fine la fototerapia
fare del bene a regalare quello che so
fare meglio ovvero la moto quindi
chiunque può regalare quello che sa fare
bene agli altri non è che deve fare i
salti mortali
io ho fatto questo salto
do il meglio di me con questi ragazzi e
poi dopo che loro mi vedono volare mi
vedono tutto colorato in cielo come un
power ranger acquistano fiducia
acquistano fiducia in me li porto in
moto e quando dico che porto tutti molto
vuol dire che porto tutti in moto ho
portato anche un sacco di bimbi affetti
da autismo che avevano paura salire in
macchina invece poi sono saliti con
bergamo sgommato abbia fatto mille cose
questo perché è pazzesco quello che mi
torna indietro a fare queste cose qua e
meraviglioso mi piace da morire
ogni volta che faccio queste giornate
torna a casa col sorriso e in quel
momento lì potrei anche morire non me ne
fregherebbe un cazzo perché raramente ho
il cuore pieno di gioia e pieno talmente
tanto che tutti gli sforzi nella vita
sono stati appagati credetemi che per
arrivare al livello in cui sono arrivato
io mi sono distrutto 26 ossa giorni di
ospedale sofferenze ma li atroci che
però hanno portato a una svolta
mi hanno portato a capire che fare del
bene è fighissimo
è una cosa troppo rock and roll e troppo
meravigliosa
purtroppo purtroppo c'è questo grande
motivo per cui l'ho fatto tardi perché
ha iniziato circa dieci anni fa avrei
potuto iniziare prima ma ho iniziato
tardi perché la società mette davanti a
tutti questo stereotipo sbagliato di
volontariato che il volontariato stantio
perché la maggior parte dei volontari al
giorno d'oggi sono persone disadattate
emarginate
che comunque non stanno bene con se
stesso allora si buttano sul
volontariato fare del bene ma farlo solo
peggio perché per aiutare una persona
per farla per renderla felice
devi essere tu stesso felice per
trasmettere emozioni forti e farlo
godere io faccio così io sono sempre
stato un ragazzo un uomo che ha vissuto
negli eccessi
infatti io mi dico sempre io sono sesso
moto e rock'n roll e non me ne vergogno
di niente
in chiesa non ci ha mai messo piede
il catechismo ma sempre fatto vomitare e
perché scusate non posso fare del bene
anch'io lo faccio meglio degli altri
perché l'importante è stare bene con se
stessi tutto tutto questo lungo percorso
mi ha portato appunto a capire questo
che i disabili sono persone esattamente
come noi non vanno trattati da persone
disabili
ovvero non bisogna metterli dentro
questa sfera di ovatta e guardarli da
lontano no sono persone come noi che
vanno anche mandati a fan culo senza
problema vanno toccati vanno manipolati
vanno consumati come se fossero nostri
amici
quindi se io gli devo far più far
provare qualcosa loro vi faccio provare
l'estremo quello che provo io non gli
faccio provare una cosa basilare è come
se prendessi mio amico non è che lo
porto in vespa no ti porto subito su una
delle moto più potenti che ci sono ti
faccio vedere come godo io perché è
quello lo scopo rendere tutti uguali e
sono dieci anni ormai che faccio molto
terapia la faccia in tutto il mondo lo
esportato in russia in spagna in
sudamerica
in america in francia ovunque e l'ho
portata ed è stata abbracciata da tutti
perché di gente buona al mondo ce n'è
tanta ce n'è tanto ancora ed è
meraviglioso e questo l'ha molto terapia
non assicurazioni non c'è nessuno che si
vuole prendere la responsabilità tutta
la responsabilità cade sulle mie spalle
però secondo me il progetto è talmente
alto è talmente nobile che non ne frega
niente
cioè mi prendo tutte le responsabilità e
lo faccio perché un uomo si deve
prendere le proprie responsabilità in
dieci anni avrò portato decine di
migliaia di ragazzi avessi seguito la
burocrazia non avrei portato neanche uno
vi parla appunto di questo anche per
quanto riguarda la responsabilità che
una cosa che ormai si è persa al giorno
d'oggi
la gente ormai tende a non prendersi più
responsabilità perché ha paura di
perdere il lavoro paura di perderla casa
ha paura di perdere pur di perdere che
cosa uno che non si prende la
responsabilità è già perso un uomo che
non vale niente fa schifo non partita io
per anni ho provato ad entrare negli
ospedali perché volevo portare quei
bimbi che purtroppo non possono uscire
dalle stanze gli invii malati bimbi
terminali bimbi che andranno a morire
volevo entrare lì ed era impossibile
tre anni fa ha incontrato una persona
che ha voluto prendersi la
responsabilità una caposala che si
chiama si è che si chiama sonia lei mi
ha detto vanni viene la prossima
settimana che il primario in vacanza
tuenti mi prendo la responsabilità
quella donna ha rischiato il posto di
lavoro sono entrato ho fatto tutte le
cose a modo va bene benissimo perché non
sono uno scapestrato
la cosa che è piaciuta talmente tanto
che è stata resa pubblica una volta che
è stata resa pubblica
l'hanno abbracciato a tutti gli ospedali
quindi anche lì per la prima volta al
mondo
è riuscito a portare le moto in reparto
adesso mandiamo questo video che si
chiama free style hospital che vi fa
capire di cosa si tratta
[Musica]
non potevamo non portare gli auguri di
natale ai nostri piccoli amici
all'ospedale casini dice panni del vado
domani hanno chiamato volta tornato
quello che ormai
la fototerapia
mai
[Musica]
complice sono sempre quelli tostato
dell'ospedale abbiamo soltanto un po
l'atmosfera qui alle ferie
ma non tutti possono dire che qui siamo
stati noi tutti
in quella delle moto
va bene
camera
quindi il ritiro i partiti già milioni
di tutto pronto
a sinistra ma di fatto qualche umani
questa cosa penserete domani quindi si
sono articolati e lo fanno di mestiere
di armi sarà conteso proprio
testi che lo propone solo giusta di moto
con le reti di tutto ma non voglio dire
che oggi ci voglia cosa che mi fa perché
oggi ho fatto tutto bene
oggi è anche la madre si è preso un po
di baccano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa è una parte del lavoro che va da
fare durante l'anno più o meno dedico
agli altri un centinaio di giornate in
un anno un terzo della mia vita adesso
lo dedico agli altri
la cosa meravigliosa anche di questo
lavoro che sono riuscita ad accendere
tante persone perché ognuno di noi
dentro a del bene alla voglia di fare e
deve essere solo accesa l'ho notato
perché comunque io acceso i miei amici
intorno a me ea loro volta hanno acceso
gli altri ancora fino che si è creato
una catena umana lunghissima in italia e
in tutto il mondo perché basta solo
accendere le persone poi iniziano a
lavorare bene e li faccio solo un
esempio piccolo esempio questi bambini
che avete visto noi gli andiamo a
visitare ma poi entrano dentro il nostro
gruppo li attiriamo dentro di noi ce li
studiamo sui social e tutto diventano
per i nostri amici
quindi una volta che sono dentro uno sto
gruppo ogni settimana fanno qualcosa non
ci sono sempre io ma c'è il mio amico
magari che fa il fornaio che si inventa
qualcosa li porta in giro o viceversa
quindi questa catena li prende e
abbraccia e mi porta li accompagna
perché tanto la malattia non cambia però
gli rende la vita migliore la qualità
della vita gli all ars perché se lo
meritano questa catena umana
fa tutto ciò sono persone normalissime
persone come voi che non fanno i salti
mortali e che adesso lavorano meglio di
me si prendano le ferie per fare queste
cose qua sono dei grandi sono persone
che hanno smesso di spendere tempo
incazzate di vista nemmeno davanti allo
specchio e di di trattarsi medici perché
troppe persone pensano che per stare
bene devi devi curarti devi curarti
l'aspetti tutto sono cazzate devi
curarti dentro devi curare il tuo cuore
e queste persone lo stanno facendo sono
migliori
più belle quindi io spero vivamente con
tutto il cuore di avervi acceso qualcosa
dentro perché di solito lo riesco a fare
è la prima volta che mi trovi nella
situazione del genere e vi lascio
dicendo solo questo che fare del bene
credetemi perché io di cose nella vita
ne ho fatte tante
dalle più assurda anche le più normali
ma fare del bene la cosa più il rock and
roll del mondo e vi ripeto filettine
fighettini andatevene affanculo tutti
[Applauso]